New York City baby listen up and listen
good the tickets for the third show at
the Gramercy theater are going faster a
couple of tickets left do yourself a
favor and grab them before they're gone
yeah time is running out gang very
limited tickets left to the show on
February 3rd Friday night get them while
supplies last we'll see you there we're
gonna blow the roof off the place
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey yeah that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're going
to be classy yeah they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host stage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day a rainy
day we're down here in antuti's basement
she's upstairs got a nice dinner waiting
for us okay I'm gonna put on a movie
cleaned up the house real good yeah man
she's all smoked up up there she's cheap
places a mess what are you talking about
yeah I think she's stealing my change my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table here's what we call the good
old-fashioned Family episode gang just
the boys just the squad just the homies
just the bozos he's my best pal in the
whole wide world okay thank you Kevin
James Ryan everybody hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rape you subscribe on iTunes that'd
be nice full video available on YouTube
you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously still subscribed
though of course I mean we need
everything we can always be cooking a
little more I can always turn
the heat up a bit over there on the old
YouTube uh and then obviously the
greatest gosh darn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there and I just did the math
today I was over there peeking at that
greatest website helpful I gotta check
in on her make sure the servers don't go
down you know 15 million hours of bonus
content there's over a hundred episode
bonus episodes of ayg right there's over
a hundred episodes of that gosh darn
hard feelings as well which the kids
love there's about 11 or 12 just bonus
videos or about 10 12 minutes long of us
on the road the cribs are sure uh the
golf outing I forgot we did the limo
ride Dave and Buster's Dave and Buster
ten thousand dollar bet I genuinely
forgot about that until today I didn't
it's tax time Jam me up yeah check it
out gang we appreciate all the love and
support and also we announced our new
goal at 8 500 patrons which is coming in
real quick by the way we're
going to the Indy 500 yes we are we're
doing all three days over there at Indy
Friday Saturday Sunday it's going to be
a good time it's a whole weekend I'm
debating a mullet definitely gonna dress
like the local
[Laughter]
have sex with your sister
that's a nice Town how are your cousin
I'm kidding I can't wait and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer X
Jordan Air the magic man makes us all
look good he works those ones Works
those twos crosses those t's and dots
those eyes but doesn't comb that hair
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody hey pal hey what's up
dudes what up team I can't wait for the
Indy 500 dude I've already cut off all
the sleeves on every shirt I have yeah
it's gonna be a good one we're gonna go
full native dude never been to the track
also I gotta say dog track the you know
the powers that be
uh a homie knows somebody who knows
somebody who knows somebody the Indy 500
reached out to me the other day and I
get to go in a car for two laps not
joking and I get to take police
I get to do two laps around a track and
a dual Cedar Indy car 180 miles an hour
I want to be pulled in a little uh wagon
or something
I'm gonna be coming in that seat dude
that Rumble
Feel It In My Bones I'm gonna need
waterproof pants Oh man slipping out of
my goddamn chair you ever go I'm gonna
make a move on the driver he better be
ready you ever go buck 80 you ever get
up to speed a buck 80. what have you
done what's the most you've done I
smoked weed once that way what do you
mean the most I don't know probably 120.
fell off the girl 120 130 on the Aldo
Bond really probably wow thousand
kilometers I don't know what was going
on it's doing three million yen an hour
I don't know dude I'm breaking a sound
barrier nine Deutsche marks a minute I
was in a car in Mexico and I looked over
it the guy was driving crazy I looked
over like it was going 190. still doing
380. what the man
six degrees outside roasting hot I can't
do the math deck I don't know I was
cooking to the point where I was nervous
sure driving which I would have guessed
is it's over a hundred I'll do a hunter
on the way home today I've done about
probably 120. I've done about a buck did
a buck one time driving back from the
shore I was petrified yeah because
you're you're a you're a lazy Susan
behind the wheel it was my brother it
was my older brothers every day is a sun
that the Sunday drive with you Jesus
Christ falling asleep behind a wheel
driving back from the shore my older
brother's buddy was driving uh this is
high school obviously don't
recommend it he had a couple in them
drinking Gatorade and vodka cruising up
the AC gotta stay hydrated kids doing
about a buck I was shotgun in my
pants yeah finally I stopped them and I
was like dude you gotta stop this you're
freaking me the out why weren't you
just driving or you were also I don't
think I had a license Jesus yeah it's
always tough when a kid I mean Toby
obviously no no no no no no no no no
it's not like I was 25 dude I was
with 15. oh okay yeah
they were about 17. okay I could have
took the wheel yeah why not I was too
busy making out with chicks
no I wasn't yeah I doubt it too busy
tucking your wiener up in your belt loop
probably it's funny you mentioned that
because they all showed up we were down
on my buddy's parent shorehouse and it
was off season it was like March and
then the older kids rolled in a couple
of dudes couple of Honeys and they were
I mean they were getting there
swapping yeah sleeping in the same room
some boning going on doing a little
a little Peaks all right caught them
also one time you just sound like a
creep dude I don't know what to tell you
I was under the bed while they were
going to town on each other I did a
sleepover at my house and my brother had
all his boys over
um they were playing strip poker up
there and we were down in that little
thing so we could look right up there
used to be an accordion door you know
when you look downstairs into the shark
there's not a lot of places to hide in
that house by the way yeah you can you
can see every corner from the every from
every angle but there's some titties out
there aren't
got a lampshade on your head standing in
the corner mushing your ween on the wall
good times good good times you were told
days you were talking before about no I
wasn't a teacher
yeah sending a letter home to your mom
asking her to help me help your son
which got you jammed up oh yeah I think
that fluid then he's I got pinched
really hard I might have mentioned this
to you before but when I was in fourth
grade uh I walked into my classroom and
grabbed my crotch and went hey how you
doing like one of those things real
highbrow humor back then too I see
what's up hey I followed it up with some
cello playing
um and my teacher caught me and she
freaked out and she starts walking me
down to the to the principal and I don't
know if like we got jammed up on like
the time she's like if you do one more
thing I'm taking you down there I'm like
oh my God thank you so much sure as
like two hours later we're
running in the hallway jumping up off of
like a trash can and putting our hands
in the drop ceilings to knock them out
good clean fun good clean fun get
pinched though yeah she's like that's it
took me to the principal's office got in
trouble she's like I'm calling your mom
now this is 80s Patty
at the height of her pattiness oh you
like grabbing dicks do you well now
you're gonna grab every dick in your
class why don't you grab my dick it's
funny you mentioned that you're probably
smoking a three-foot heater too
[Laughter]
common correct so uh they call home I
get home she's like what were you doing
knocking out tiles and I'm like oh thank
God knocking out tiles whatever all
right that's nobody grabbing your little
roof no so she yells at me for
that I'm getting screamed at
dinner homework go upstairs I'm naked in
my bathroom getting into the tub Tubby
Time and out of nowhere she
Steven Seagal kicks the door open and
grabs her crotch she shoots it with a
shotgun blows the line blows the lock
off so she can get it
hits it with the Buckshot
comes off there oh you know you
know I'm surgical with this don't
you Hank I just see a flashbang slowly
rolling it gets real quiet
she comes in she grabs her crotch and
she goes and whoever taught you this
probably hurt I thought you were gonna
say she ran in and grabbed yours yeah
you like that dude
I couldn't get hard for about two years
man
talk about vulnerable I was naked
getting in I was covering my wiener as
she came in she's like whoever taught
you this man
talk about a mom that's wild a mom
grabbing her own sneeze she
didn't like it Patty didn't play that's
wild drug my fat ass down a confession
the next day I remember I uh one time
about third fourth grade something I
told our our uh our gym teacher that his
class blows
I had a real mouth on me back then
you call this a kickball you piece of
yeah he made me he was
his name uh it was Mr Whitmer and he
good gym teacher name he was oh and he
played the part had the stash had the
Whistle the track pants the matching
code like real early 90s you know
leftover strong guy type stuff we had Mr
Smith you know in uh middle school and
he was the closest thing to Mr T that I
had ever met and he was awesome
yeah had the lines everything shirt
tails in shoes tied up catching
his School stadium do your drugs yeah
catch up catch you playing grab ass
latch on you good man he would
uh he taught us to shoot a basketball
like this
they would call it the Whitmer W and
what's like he just ruined my chances of
going pro right there by teaching me the
wrong fundamentals
and you pull he would do that you would
sit there and I'm like this is all right
boys I'm gonna teach you how to be last
in state nine years running teach you
how to be picked last 101. hope you boys
like it and swirlies and nuggies uh
cause you're gonna be throwing underhand
yeah that and he would you would granny
shoot it if you couldn't pull off the
Whitmer W if your hands were too small
or too sticky or whatever
you would do the under the degree and he
goes there ain't no shame in the granny
shot I'm like buddy it's not your ass
getting kicked out of here I'd rather
air ball well my air ball a three than
be at the foul line shooting green I
don't know there is no shame because
those always go in man when you
underhand it that's clean living right
there so I told him his class blows and
then he and right away goes
what'd you say I'm like I'm like this is
gonna get back to my dad for sure
school-wise my mom took it like grade
wise that was my mom's if I was being a
jerk off which I tend to be that went to
hell the old man yeah homie call your
father which sucks he's got to come get
me so you were just waiting in
Purgatory for three hours so we came
yeah man wait till I'm telling your dad
and he you know and you would hear him
on the other line I'll be there at 7 30.
brutal yeah it sucks
I need to get in the car behind him so
he couldn't reach him you sit directly
behind him so he can't if you
sit behind the passenger seat or not the
front he's got you with the right but
directly behind him have a piano
wire take him out he got to do
mob moves to get away from your dad's
right that's a tough one I did that too
I'll be in the trunk I slide back behind
the seat I could use a cardio I'm gonna
walk all right I'll meet you over there
I need to get my steps in
got not get lumped up I remember
years later I would look back and be
like man that must have is
working all day then he gets a
call around three four o'clock from the
from the misses but he's doing dead he's
grabbing his crap he's got to be like
what the man he's gonna drive home
traffic come in doesn't even get
to relax first thing
she would wrap me the out while I
was standing right there there'd be no
eye contact eye contact made it looked
like it was blowing over that's how they
always they always Rope A Dope deal not
a quick rant you go I might I might be
free and clear of this they might have
forgot wrong and if you dodge that first
backhand it only gets worse yeah you
gotta take a dive
say you say you scratched my corny or
something they'll fall back a little bit
oh man you gotta go down but I told him
his class blows and then uh he
got a meat he told and he told my music
teacher and this chick was
about she had to be pushing 380. she was
huge dude she wore moo moos every day
huge like
big big gal we called her the lice ball
and hindsight you know what it wasn't
the best thing
but I mean you put a 380 pound lady as
your teacher to 10 10 year olds they're
gonna be snickering I can't imagine what
children think when they see me I told
you I remember I thought I told you
there's there's two Chinese kids in
Austin saw you they were staring at you
like you were a science experiment I
told you your uh your your nieces and
nephews at the at the funeral as I came
around after coming out of the line they
were standing in like The Little Rascals
looking at me like I was Shrek
just for your autograph
and less Green in person
yeah nah yeah you can't do that
um but yeah they called a meeting with
all the They we called them specials
like gym music art whatever they were
like the you know electives electives
but in elementary school so they uh you
had one a day and dude they had all
those teachers in me and I had to sit
down and like apologize to all of them
on behalf of this who
complained that I said his class blows
but I was dude and they were like we're
not gonna tell your parents I was like
my man I am so sorry you guys are great
I'm an see you later Jay right
yeah anyway no never made it never made
it to the rents yeah which I they I
respect their word sure they did all
right sure yeah not bad not bad
um but yeah let's do a couple of uh
garbage questions over them over there
on a goddamn patreon a couple of cues
huh yeah dang as you know when you sign
up for the old patreon there get a
question right on the air by Kevin James
Ryan himself look at him hey how are you
too by the way I got a couple of these
get used to these you're gonna be seeing
them a whole was that from the uh the
Soho shopping spree that I heard about a
couple Saturdays ago this was really
he's fitting in the stuff down there huh
what do you mean I mean you're poorly
fella yeah but I mean it's I mean when
you get down there you gotta be but
there's two days no there's two
different down theirs it's like regular
stores or like the cool I don't go to
the cool guy stores no catch me a fancy
store for me would be a Banana Republic
it's all right in here they make you
feel real nice yeah they do
um but uh this is Kelly Slater's company
nice I shred there you go Hang Ten huh
yeah do it all baby real poser in the
building
look over I got my nose done in white
did you say this guy don't grind Kelly
Slater's a surfer dude even better
you can grind on a surfboard
you can't one guy yeah you can catch the
head of a whale or something like that
that would be a bonk I will believe
really shout out to Windows bomb all
right Fair
um all right let's get into it we got a
couple of hum thingies here this one's
from Woody is it garbage if your dad
takes a snorkeling in the local water
parks Lazy River to find jewelry on the
greats to pawn later that's I respect
that's like magnificent in the early
days I respect that that's a lazy river
like a water park right yeah at the yeah
he says is it garbage if your dad takes
you snorkeling in the local water parks
Lazy River to find jewelry on the greats
man that's a good time at first I
thought scuba if I saw a scuba guy in
The Lazy River freaked the out
figure he's fishing on the body you
would presume
uh Frogman that's as a kid that's gotta
be fun like my sense of an adventure I'd
be like dude I got a job this is great
we're going treasure hunting you're
treasure hunting in a piss River yeah
they got chlorine in there you figure
those Dirtbag kids that worked there
probably
cleaned it out first yeah but like how
nice of jewelry is being worn in the
Lazy River you never know not I'm just
not that nice I would no one's wearing a
Rolex in there find a nice
engagement ring ripped a diamond out
they held it down take that over to the
guys that are to a local smelter
boiler down yeah man that's a tough look
that's trash I wonder if he got anything
juicy though
yeah I don't know should have said if
you have a water park fence you are a
different type of dirt bag what do you
mean oh offense like you're removing
merch yeah yeah that's wild you're the
Dirtbag that works at the water park you
find some you go to a guy and move
start moving it or like yeah or I mean I
would they would have to find it
someone's gonna get it somebody's coming
back for it right not necessarily really
I mean if I lost something in a water
park would you find this it's like it
was my ring or some earrings I
know but like the chances of finding
something in a it could have fallen off
on a slide which ends up in the pool
which ends up at the bottom of that you
know what they say I'm a shotgun full I
don't know shout out to shotgun Falls
shout out to it gilliam's water appeared
Ocean City New Jersey it's where
I became a man walking up those steps
petrified yeah pet and it was the back
of the boardwalk though
yeah and you go up there and you look
over where like the parking lot is you
can smell the hot ketchup you just know
that your brains at splatter all over
over the pavement if you fell I
just did one when we were uh when I was
down in uh Florida with my family the
like neighborhood that we stayed in the
Airbnb had like a not a resort but like
a pool and they had water slides really
and it's like we did the mats and you
walk up there and it's like I still get
scared dude a staircase with nothing
under it you can just oh
manhole I used to get scared looking
down into the bleachers
no man oh no that was all right
but dude walking it's like anything if I
fall
I just I I feel it in my butthole now
I'm like you know you get that feeling
in your belly button did you do the
thing that jumps off into the into the
water no we just did the mats where you
ride and this thing was a little shoddy
I mean like I don't yeah you know OSHA
wasn't there earlier that day
you know checking off the safety list
this thing was just you know put your
screws later yeah it was no Raging
Waters it was just like a pool that had
these two crazy slides okay they seemed
way too big to be there not in with a
completely closed because I don't
with those I mean I wouldn't get one now
obviously yeah yeah yeah no this one
wasn't but they did have a closed one
and a regular one you feel that heat in
the darkness I like it that Kim how
about that butcher box
I got a freezer full of meat that'll
choke effect oh man they just dropped
heavy bike boxes on all three if I shout
out to the boys and girls over there
butcher box fresh ground turkey fresh
turkey breast grass fed grass finish
beef I I got some steak tips I got some
this I got some that I'm telling you I'm
stocked and I just realized we realized
when we go to the grocery store we don't
got to get any meat get vegetables get
this get that we're good for the month
I'm good for the apocalypse they must
have sent me two three boxes guys
butcher box takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality Meat and seafood uh
humanely raised no antibiotics no added
hormones enjoy a range of high quality
cuts at an amazing price plus free
shipping in a continental US no surprise
fees but your box has a special offer
running for our listeners baby use code
ayg to get 20 off your first box we're
talking Cold Hard Cash a dub right off
your first box sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg and use code ayg to get twenty
dollars off do it baby love that butcher
box Kevin how about that displayed baby
this plate top got one posters on
one-of-a-kind metal you guys there
fantastic fantastic product if you
didn't get what you wanted for Christmas
do yourself a favor get over to this
plate they got deals with Netflix they
got deals with Star Wars they got deals
with marble they got deals with Call of
Duty you got cool stuff we got Seinfeld
over here yeah your posters come with a
magnetic sticker so you just pop it on
the wall and hang your poster no power
tools no wall damage it's easily switch
out new post 30 seconds uh we got the
Cosmo Kramer right here where big
Seinfeld guys everybody knows somebody
breaks in the house you can Whack Him
over the head what's the deal with old
posters grab yourself a display uh click
the link in our description to see some
of your favorite this place and save up
to 29 other people giving 10 15. 29 is a
Lot 29 it's Flying Too Close to the sun
You're Gonna Lose the money this plate
there you go uh you get 25 off when you
buy one or two and 29 off when you buy
three or more discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use the code
garbage baby you know it you love it use
code Garbage When you visit
thisblate.com that's display.com code
garbage or click the link in the show
notes do it now back to that gosh darn
show back to the show all right let's
see here this one's from Jeff ten dollar
homie never had one red is a garbage to
rent a car anytime you have to drive
more than a couple hours to avoid any
car troubles
I guess if your rig's not good enough to
make it two three hours back and forth I
get that though better than getting
jammed up yeah plus they got them I'm
sure it's some roadside if you have a
Budget rent a car is on the side of the
road they're gonna go get it 100 what I
mean you don't got to worry about it
yeah you got some sort of uh contingency
I would I would presume but my my
Montego and the loom every car I've had
up until now the Kia shout out to her
the Forte
to each had times when I'm like I don't
I don't go down the shore anymore
it doesn't drive back to like when I
have my Montego here there was times
where I'm like it doesn't go to Philly
it's just for scooting around sure
locally you know what I mean like a golf
cart yeah exactly local like a low you
know low power vehicle or whatever
something run to the store that's what I
would use it for like I would go to work
when I was working outside the city like
20 minutes but I'm like I I don't trust
it doing 65 on a Parkway the whole way
home not gonna do it or the turnpike
I'll give you that trashy yes but we
gotta do what you gotta do you know what
I mean but it's also like if you rent a
car I don't know rental cars in New York
feels like you're getting a new car it's
probably nicer than a car you got but it
feels real good yeah getting out there
yeah whipping something real nice yeah I
had a shitty it wasn't shitty but it got
shitty Honda Accord hatchback when I
lived in Wilmington and I got into a
accident
brought it over to Jeff Gordon Chevy
they were fixing it they gave me a
renter uh it was a Pontiac
Grand Prix or something like
when those dropped they were that's that
was the car I wanted dude sick a black
one of those a Grand Am or Graham Grand
Am and Grand peas they Kate they Grand
Prix they can't they redid them probably
in 2000
Pontiac ain't still floating around 2001
probably they redid them maybe they came
out hot real real cool yeah it redid the
bottle they weren't boxy they were
rounded yeah we had a uh it was a
Pontiac I want to say 6 000 or maybe it
was a Grand Am something burgundy
two-seater yikes couldn't tell my mom at
that yeah two door well you had a
crawl in the back I hated that
oh trap we were just talking uh my
stepdad growing up had a Ford Ranger a
little guy and they had those jump seats
in the back do you remember those yeah
we had them we had them in the back of
our our truck too I don't know my mom
was like what do you thought we were
telling her and I'm like yeah we used to
ride around in though she's like that's
not safe I'm like I know but what the
you were she's like I didn't know
that I'm just baby I'm just
cruising I feel like a flight attendant
when the turbulence hits Dead
Heading to school
yeah that's wonky that's good stuff uh
this one's for Michael first time long
time you ever gets you ever
get stopped driving into the car wash
because you're because your car has body
damage and the guy doesn't want the risk
of breaking his machine if he gets
caught on your car
that's wild I never had that but when I
worked at a car wash this old
lady pulled up in a minivan and you know
you pull up you let the thing catch and
you put it in neutral this dumb
broad just drove through it and
jammed it up and then got
out like what the hell's going on I
don't know understand stupid
I'll tell you what's going on the
I'm talking about holding a grudge
dude Jesus Christ poor old lady's
probably dead
um cost me my weekend money
kind of shut down for a couple of days a
couple of walking around boxer out uh
I used to operate I mean my cars have
always been tough a 96 Chevy Loom and I
had a I want to say a 2004 Mercury
Montego but I got it probably
2012 or something like that I was always
at the point where
99 of the time I would have to clean my
car to go get my car cleaned if that
makes sense because it wasn't in shape
to give to the guy to start vacuuming
and a lot of the times all the the
trash the whatever that was in my car
just got thrown in my trunk and still
does and then they'll just be like bags
of trash in my trunk you do keep it
pretty messy the car yeah you live in it
you really do I just don't you got the
dog I get it yeah it's now it's like I'm
not in it we get in it we drive a half
hour we park it we drive back apart and
I leave it for weeks you know what I
mean I'm not in it if I was in it every
day I would keep it tighter because I'm
you know spending time in there sure but
I mean I don't use her that much you
know what I mean yeah
uh this one's from pepperoni Tony shout
out that's a killer Name by the way new
ten dollar homie is there garbage if
your parents is it garbage for your
parents to let you play on the showroom
swing set and never actually buy one
man hey you poor bastard that's a shame
come take a ride on what you don't have
yeah that's like going to test drive a
Porsche
all right I'm thinking about bombing the
market for one we did like that a
lot I felt like on a Saturday we'd go
and like test drive a car they had no
intentions on buying they'd go and like
look at a house just for shits and
giggles we do stuff like that we go yeah
go look at a jungle gym or like
a hot tub for a little while they were
real big on kicking the tires yeah
stringing people along yeah
ah
hey everybody get in the car let's go
get some strangers hopes up I know right
literally let's go jerk around a guy
trying to make rent
I remember uh we went down to my cousins
for Easter and they had a piano and I
was playing the piano and looking I I it
was nothing but my mom thought I was the
next Johann Sebastian and she
was like uh she's like he played a
Chopsticks or something he's perfectly
which I didn't I was just
banging it like a and man I
remember we spent about two hours in
this piano store walking on a Yamaha
dude my mom's drinking this dude
along for like a three thousand dollar
no way was ever good my son's a
prodigy you know that you can't
smoke in here
he had me play and I was just like
that's one of those things that rich
people do do I think is play the piano
right like that's like a rich person
classy classy that richness sorry classy
She's Gotta Have space for a piano they
ain't small
we have that one that plays itself sure
that was all right Mexico and I think
I'm pretty sure my stepdad like he's
talking about the laboratory what
getting in the lab setting the
oh the samba on the Casio no that wooden
one that's in the intro to the show that
you're sitting at oh wait oh that's
right that does that's like a double
yeah yeah I don't know that's like the
thing where you shoot the BB at the on
the boardwalk and the guy starts playing
I never like that I never liked when
that plot so that's that was the
coolest thing to make
he got that off somebody something he
didn't buy that he got it like found it
in like an auction or a garage sale or
something and ended up with it and we
thought he was like even when he moved
in he brought a piano and we were like
who the is this dude Jesus Christ
he's a mayor man your fat ass in there
hiding snacks in it open it off I just
got a six or a Diet Coke
it's a refrigerator you open it up it's
all lined with dry ice you put these
Hawaiian rolls in here hey get out of my
head stash will you fell
my sister-in-law can play like
I literally like four notes or something
you know what I mean because she like
took it as a kid she can play like three
notes of something just important you go
oh that's that song type thing and she
did it one time and I mean my mom you
would have thought my mom was like
everybody gather around Lauren's gonna
play his song all our troubles are over
yeah dude it was and she's like I can't
place you just like knew like you know
the intro to something
yeah it was still Dre uh I was on the
sacks for a minute in uh in elementary
school got the sacks for a couple of
weeks ah yeah I never I never did that
that dropped in about third grade you
could play the violin the viola the
cello fresh too brand new yeah that
was some sort of scam Ben Patty found
out they were charging her every week
and like the music place was written it
and people get right out of my
hands that's nuts I remember they gave
us a recorder and I was like dude I'm
not touching this thing they're
like it's eight bucks I'm like
give me something with some Distortion
will you yeah I was on the alto sax
Kenny G and it up all that I
went to hey is that the little one no
that's the uh that's just fun big guy
little sex is a good time no I wasn't
this fat in elementary school Toby
believe it or not I was 800 pounds
it was the alto it was the good one not
the big one not the little one I could
be wrong maybe I'm I I'm pretty sure
Alto was was the one I played the
regular sacks I wanted a guitar I wanted
to shred so bad on a guitar I got the
bass right there
oh is that still there yeah so many
people I guess I said I'd sell it or
something or best offer I mean dude they
were coming out of the woodwork first of
all half of them spelled bass wrong too
by the way a lot of bases
what I wet my beak on that as a gift no
it was an unreceived GIF no I received
it I don't think it's all nice out of
the studio
nine tenths in a long what are you gonna
do
um I wanted to shred so bad and I took
lessons at uh House of guitar in
Feasterville Pennsylvania man it was
like walking into 1972 bearded or beaded
curtain and you had to get I
remember my dad was like dude I'm never
going back in now I'll just drop you up
and pick you up drop you off and pick
you up out front this dude had a fro and
he was mad weird I just wanted to shred
and he taught me Barney my first day I
was Barney the song that's the theme
song the Barney was what he taught me
that dude's trying to I was like
dude I can't I can't go
into school and shred this
another dude I had me his name was Jay
and Jay was like real left over from the
80s like long hair metal his his
band name was metal wolf I think they're
still banging those guys were kind of
looked up with their parents they always
spelled like cigs they wore a fanny pack
really you know he wore sweatpants and a
fanny pack and a bulge that was just
he was hanging dong no on these
just me and him in like a closet in his
his little division signs
showing
yeah and I was like I remember just
being like dude this is too weird man
he taught me bass I think they're like
being in confessionals in those things
you couldn't turn the bait like I had we
both had to be like long ways with it
because you couldn't it was literally
like a closet that was DeFelice
music for me hey little dude I know you
want to learn guitar but I need a
bassist so yeah so you're gonna learn
bass because we're going on tour in
February
is your mom cool or what can we use your
van dude I know you got a ranger for uh
you guys won't remember this but for a
long time in New York City you would
always see flyers for this guitar coach
named Dan Smith
yeah Dan Smith will teach you guitar Dan
Smith will teach you guitar I
went and took lessons with him for a few
months couple months maybe okay dude he
was awesome one of the coolest
guys I ever met really dude in every act
like a guru and he really held he really
huh
what he said that kind of odd Guru he
said it okay guru guru guru
you're a smart guy
um but an actual great teacher too
taught me about
um scales and this and that and the
blues scale all right that didn't make
any jokes
piece of I'd let it go ball one hey
taught me about scales you can't trust
them they all lie I am big pentameter in
how things translate from like piano to
guitar and the notes and like the 145
progression and all this stuff it was
really really great good teacher there
you go shout out to him if you're out
there shout out man
now if you're out there check out metal
wolf
they're actually kind of popping dude
they got 71k views and a couple songs
there you go yeah
damn we play one what's the name of a
song I don't want to I don't want Jay to
come in and not like it wouldn't come
and sue me promoting down to the wire
There You Go Korea was real like heavy
metal you know airband heavy
metal that dude that was that was a
very cozy time I used to love those kids
or like the older kids that were like
really in the metal and stuff like that
they weren't dick heads they were always
the sweetest dudes they were
always cool as like if some bird
that babysit us like her boyfriend was a
little older maybe in a band you
know he'd come over and hang out he was
always cool as oh we never
had that wait what was it knocked the
bottom out of her like what we were
upstairs taking her to pee town
what was the name of the guy who gave
you a scumbag Johnny Smith what Johnny
Smith no Jay Jay I believe I was singing
Jack because the guy who uploaded was
Johnny Smith I thought I thought it
might be something I think that's their
web guy trying to get the shout out to
them no I think their their web guy is a
guy who up to go to the whole album
which is lion throcifer like
anthrosopher metal metal culture is the
dumbest of all no you're crazy
that's awesome dude
shout out to them well it's all like
disabled Cyclops and that's what
they get into all right yeah there it is
JB Jans
you and your New Kids on the Block or
whatever you're listening though
punk Tony Tony man myself Tony Tony the
group Tony Tony was all right
be talking about Tony Tony
cooling the gang was up there too
um all right let's see here uh this
one's from Professor spongeworthy is it
garbage to intentionally it's a Seinfeld
cut yeah is it garbage to intentionally
not do your physical therapy so you
still look up up when you
go to court for your workers comp case
I'm gonna put the bomb on yeah that's I
mean hey
I guess if you could do it I don't rent
a 10K that's a 10K limp don't recommend
I don't recommend insurance fraud
obviously I would never but is that
technically fraud
I don't know if he's seriously injured
enough to have to take maybe he can't go
to maybe maybe he can't get out of bed
to go yeah that's what it is his
injuries preventing him and also too
they might do that so they can screw you
on the settlement oh well you're getting
better yeah but that the pain and
suffering and time off and all that kind
of stuff then after you hit it really
hard I think we get a cash settlement
see where we're at you know what I mean
yes and figure it out yes yeah yeah
be careful there's no private eye out
outside taking pictures of you jumping
on the trampoline or nobody did that for
a couple Summers you were saying yeah
had to get his car tinted out
and everything he said it was brutal
yeah but it was wild I sitting
there with the binoculars just
the Stakeout would seem fun but for
about two hours sure a cup of coffee or
two a pack of heaters you're having a
good meatball sandwich too yes Good Sam
Gary Busey had a Point Break someone but
that guy's always your partner always
goes and comes back I think I got you a
sandwich in a Coke bag of chips sandwich
and a cup of coffee is all right I can't
do that oh I love that can I say
something controversial please I think
the meatball sandwich is completely
overrated man this don't like
meatball subs don't like heavy
metal
[Laughter]
I mean they're good they're good they're
really good I like bread
okay
so who don't like a nice meat beef you
made me never had a sometimes at the
pizza place they go too much with how
they put it together then they put it in
the pizza oven which kind of it up
yeah no but on a nice soft roll fresh
meatballs if you slice them in half a
little bit of mozzarella some Parmesan
it ain't bad my best one is Easter at my
Aunt Patty's house down the shore they
got the got the meatballs going in the
crock pot
you get those short little like you know
the little Banger roll like the little
like half shout out to core police they
make the best that slice you take two
pieces of provolone that have been
sitting there a little bit they're
sweating yeah pop them in then two
meatballs but maybe some some grated
parm if it's there that's I mean you
can't go crazy with the G you can't
cover it you can't throw it back in the
oven they go to pizza place they go
crazy with them that's like they make it
like they've never had one it's crazy
yeah I'm realizing now I think I've only
ever had a Subway meatball sandwich dang
I wouldn't kick that out of bed either
back in the day it was okay I mean come
on what are we talking about here I'm
gonna say something even more
controversial that you guys are probably
gonna give me for but I'm looking
to connect with you
what ain't too bad okay stepdad is a is
a meatball Hoagie okay you get them you
get the meatball hero it's cut in half
as you're biting it not on the whole
thing as you're biting it a little hit
of mayo
fantastic
I know that's crossing the fat lines
he's a male guy I know but you're not a
male guy I do like Mayo just not to the
point where I'm dipping a sandwich in it
I mean that's crazy
you're acting like it's a juice sauce
are you getting this at all yeah I can
see that yeah but I I would also argue
dipping Mayo on most hot sandwiches
probably pretty good so like you're not
being like I'll give you this it's
pretty awesome but but normally
you wouldn't mix uh Italian food
marinara sauce with mayo
sure I mean you're like it's just like
two traditional thinking would keep you
away so I'm a forward thinker I'm a
renegade a rebel sure if that's how you
want to look at it yeah okay is that
what you see yourself in your sure okay
I'm just checking oh only guy who came
in the room who can't fit into a race
car
I don't know maybe maybe if we dip you
in some mayo we'll be able to get you in
there
I don't do it anymore I'm just saying
whatever clean your room sure sure this
is in the same world this is two kids in
a trench coat that's a good name is a
garbage or bring your own bottle of
ranch to a restaurant with you I had a
girlfriend who would put it a bottle in
her purse because these places don't got
good Ranch
okay I I don't that's not my cup of tea
I always felt for the most part
I was a Hidden Valley man obviously
Hidden Valley Ranch that's the best sure
but I always felt for the most part not
these days because these days you know
what they use they use a lot of Kens and
Ken's can kick rocks they're
honey mustard blows
but back in the day I always felt like
restaurant Ranch was so much better than
home Ranch like the industrial like the
big five gallon bucket they would like
do you remember some generic Warehouse
supplier type I don't know if you guys
are too young to remember this but the
salad bars they used to have at places
whether it was Wendy's Ponderosa sure
or a local plate Pizza Hut
they're ranch dressing with the
spoon it was thinner
and it was loaded with herbs and
spices so good without her skimping on
you giving you a beet bag something yeah
it ain't the same I saw a great video of
a British guy trying sauces from all
over the world right and he gets to
America and he's like all right we're
gonna try The American ranch sauce which
I've never had seems disgusting talking
so much about the ranch it takes
one bite and it's just like oh oh my
goodness you can't stop it yeah welcome
to America buddy yeah it's
fantastic
um
I I I I don't I mean rolling anywhere
with your own salad dressing is a tough
look it's that's a tough for sure a
tough look but I respect it
I don't know I don't know if you're
going to a place that you know where you
know
it's gonna require a lot of ranch and
you know their Ranch is beat more power
to you I don't know I'd recommend the
booth you sit closest to the wall slide
that out squirt it on a plate put it
away
that's so trash that's that's trashy
it's the sneaking anything in anywhere
unless unless it's beers is trashy All
Right Toby hit me
her speakers are allowed to be snuck in
because they're charged a premium
if you go in no you can't sneak beers
into a restaurant sit down a
little different like I'm talking about
I mean sure that's a dirtbag move I have
done that though
I used to have a buddy that would go
around everywhere with a backpack and he
had a handle a uh
Captain Morgan's in it he would just get
a Coke and
yeah cash that's pretty good I don't
mind that
um I don't I was sneaking stuff in is I
don't know I was I was big on I'm not
big on it a pint of Dimitri vodka in the
breast pocket in case I needed to stop a
bullet yeah
I get that real Class Act yeah sneaking
booze is all right sneaking Ranch it
just feels like
I don't know then get something else
that you don't need Ranch that's where I
would come from I think they come from a
world where everything needs Ranch and
I'm with them when was the last time you
had Ranch me either of you I had uh
um Halal Guys white sauce which I think
is just Rancher real close to it maybe a
couple weeks ago phenomenal
on some checky delicious
it's real close to Ranch doesn't have a
lot of tahini in it which a traditional
white soft white sauce will probably
have all right this one's in the same
world this is from David is it garbage
if your family uses Chick-fil-A sauce
and salad dressing
I don't hate it man I don't hate it what
is salad dressing these days what is
salad dressing that's not true what is
salad dressing I would argue it is what
is dipping sauce what is a remoulade
what is mayonnaise what is this it's all
it's 2023 baby
it's all non-binary no you just named
all these things that are things what's
a sauce that's a sauce what's this out
you could use as a salad dressing what's
mayo you could use Ranch as a dipping
sauce or a salad dressing
those sauces of Chick-fil-A could be
used as a salad I feel like it's too
thick you add a little work
or a little mayo or a little olive oil
I don't know my favorite salad dressing
my dad used to make it was ketchup
Worcestershire sauce mayonnaise and
parmesan cheese but I'll give you that
because that's a that's a concoction of
stuff that's his version of like Russian
dress I understand that that's a
concoction of stuff that's not just
something black olives in there that you
dip French fries in
put it on your salad that's that's that
to me you could dip your fries in that
what in that exact concoction that I
told you about I know but he's making it
this is pre-made for things to be dipped
in for French fries to be dipped into or
put you know put on a sandwich it's
honey mustard a salad dressing
I would say no
Chick-fil-A sauce is a mixture of honey
mustard barbecue and ranch the Holy
Trinity dude yeah that ain't sounds
right here I'm sorry it's good it's
fantastic those are all things that
could be in the salad
you can't put barbecue sauce on a salad
you couldn't use barbecue I'm sure
there's barbecue sauce salad dressing
give it a Google give it a barbecue
sauce
out of barbecue sauce salad dressing are
two different formulas you see what I'm
saying no one's dressing up I disagree
you find it saying you can't physically
put barbecue sauce in a second what
about Catalina that's basically barbecue
sauce or French are you a French
dressing guy no this is America I used
to lap that up like a like milk oh love
French anything that was named French or
another country I didn't with
French and blue cheese I'd mix them
together like a real fatty
this is embarrassing to admit but during
the Nate Mack episode when he said he'd
never been to Chick-fil-A he said
Chick-fil-A all Canadian and I realized
in that moment that it was Chick Filet
like it's a play on f-i-l-l-e-t a filet
whoa never put it together of chicken
correct well you didn't know that what
do you think the filet was for I just
thought it was nonsense words really I
just never thought about it yeah
Chick-fil-A fillet of chicken yeah I'm
an idiot yeah yeah I know we know
they don't do regular chicken there do
they do they do drumsticks and no
no no it's just the sandwich just the
sandwiches yeah it's just fillets it's
just fillets just a white meat yeah yeah
yeah okay all right this one's from
Lucas uh have you or anyone you know
swam while wearing denim sure
really yeah for what jean shorts in
the pool and dude there was a summer the
summer going into my junior year of high
school I wore one pair of cut off shorts
the entire summer and only ever had
shoes on when I was when I was
Landscaping the rest of the time I was
barefoot and in cut off shorts
and some kind of worn
tea that I got from like one of my
brother or from my brother passed down
from like a soccer tour today those are
the best t-shirts dude we used to go
with something Invitational or something
those t-shirts That's the older brother
or cousin wore for like three Summers
maybe had like a rip here because the
collars were a little thicker talk about
I know
it's getting late I stole a pair of
cargo shorts off my brother's boy they
were camo cargo and they were
like real beat in the perfect amount of
food I they were at that I saw them and
then he left them at the crib I was like
dude these are now ganked yeah
yeah one of my brother's boys was so
cool this kid Keith Cody shout out to
him he used to he was like
something out of a movie he was gorgeous
with lacrosse was huge
mesh shorts boxer sticking out a cool
t-shirt man I got a couple of
his teas
we probably a million bucks yeah it's
all right throw my Puka necklace on
Shark watch
necklace tough look it's bad
I did hemp necklaces when I was about 12
probably I was young I was making them
too just repellent dude oh man
maybe I was 10. I was young
to the point where like I didn't know
what it was and this kid moved from
California and like showed us hemp and
we were like what the you
hippie let's rock dude throw a bead in
that thing and let's go
yeah
oh the third page uh-huh
I am what I am bacon necklaces uh this
is from the Tikka marsala is it garbage
to keep your plates in a drawer instead
of the cabinet
yeah that's not good no then what's in
the cabinet
that's nuts put the lunch meat in the
cabinet I mean I get it kind of does
make sense a little bit
you probably stacked four in there
perfectly it's weird I don't it's not
right it's weird I haven't set a plates
in my cabinets right now that are too
big so the door doesn't close all the
way so it could be that kind of
situation how big are these plates
they're big plates Jesus Christ this is
Debo
um
that's uh yeah are you plating anything
over there
you got your factors now well they've
been getting jacked read I had my first
one today shout out to the shredded
chicken taco bowl
promo code garbage again yeah good stuff
boys I found the guy who's been stealing
my factory meals are you kidding me he
shredded
he's down 30 pounds
his skin looks amazing
yeah I shook him down you did what'd you
say I so I my it's the second week in a
row my box went missing wait really yes
second week in a row oh yeah
so I I go out I'm looking all over the
building look in the basement I look out
front I can't find this and out front
they're throwing out the recycling and
there's a bag that I don't use with a
factor box like I get and then a smaller
one in there so I look it's a clear bag
I can see the factor box I can see the
the address for the other box look at
you dude mine wasn't and I always break
mine down it was my name on the box box
wasn't broken down so I went and had a
little chat with Danny in A1 you did
Colombo I like it dog and one
more thing I knock out I knock on the
door no no answer I call the super I'm
like yo someone's been stealing my
packages I need the security cam footage
from the lobby
who are you this is wild taken
no prisoners okay that's what
he's doing look at this after I'm
calling him in the lobby I'm about to go
back upstairs and I go I'm like dude
this I know this guy's home I walk
back over the door I lean I hear him in
there so I knock on the door and
I go Danny I know you're in there get
out here dude I'm probably making a
sensible lunch right now man
better had all your facts straight oh
yeah
I did the guy was super nervous but also
I'm like he's got a crazy guy at his
doors probably high and you're yelling
at him
so I go hey bro you get Factory meals
he's like yeah I'm like I think you got
mine dude and he goes uh my partner is
is much older he doesn't know what's
going on yeah right so
where's the other box for him that's
what I said I said well if you have they
came today do you have the box in there
we can just see if you had got my box
and he goes ah no I already threw it out
real shady and I go all right do you
have venmo and he goes yeah I go all
right hit me with the cash bro
damn venmo me on the spot right
then and there really shook him down
complete yeah that's admission to guilt
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah look
at you a little Shakedown in the
building dude could you give him a
little and don't let this happen again
no after after I knew he was gonna pay
me back I was like oh who gives a I
was like I was like real cool it's like
yeah no it happened it's all good
wow but you you this was all you were
speaking in oh yeah no of course I
understand everybody knew what was going
on oh yeah yeah he knew he got got and
Toby did the right thing of not really
what a piece of you two
weeks in a row you're stealing from your
neighbor
do you think he does get it and just
messed up like there was some sort of
mix up or you think he's is he foolish
she's just stealing it I I I hold on let
me ask you this you've never seen other
Factor boxes anywhere in the building
correct of course not but then also he
would have two back boxes of factors
yeah they both got delivered that day
correct but you don't know if he was on
your same delivery schedule no they show
up at the same time
factors gonna set they in fact they have
a messenger service man in fact there's
really getting the plugs on this
one they they better be paying triple so
they wow he would have had the one of
the boxes in there oh without question
so he doesn't get fact there but she
should using promo code garbage you
should tell him hey man you like you
like what you're having I can save you
30 no no they do get they do get factors
the person does yes and they were just
grabbing mine along with theirs doubling
up whoa you know you doubled up
everybody looks at the label hey
Toby McMullen that's like about 30 meals
or whatever yeah it's a lot
piece of damn look at that man and
tried to it was
delivered that day oh yeah so he knew
who was knocking on the door oh yeah it
was either you or the cops
and he knew not to answer the
door probably smell the zoodles coming
from the kitchen
piece of
man I know how to chop a zucchini
through that factor that really
bothers me because I hate that
stealing package of of course hate
it
yeah it felt awesome plus my girl breaks
my balls whenever they not now but at
the old apartment man
I'm like just hit up Amazon I'll
send you another one yeah I don't I
don't I don't lose too much sleepover
because it's like it's the principle of
it and it's let me tell you something
it's always an inside job not in the
burbs but nine times out of ten if you
live in a building it's some
scumbag in your building it's
not some high school kid was walking by
some I'll get some no a lot of times
it's a inside job nah yes it's
half and half It's gotta be Toby yeah
that's one you can't use that as the
rule for everything there's constantly
footage of people sneaking into
buildings and stealing when they
booby trap them what do you mean one guy
that in his pants oh yeah one dude
put like an M80 or something and he
rigged something and this dude
grab this oh my God
falls into the grass shits his pants one
of my favorite videos is the guy uh the
girl running away that breaks her ankle
no the guy reaches through uh oh with
the bat yeah he's reaching through the
mail slot to unlock the door and
there's just this dude with a metal bat
that's a sound from Tom and Jerry
that's all that's I don't even I'm not
even just not not even the audio the ACT
of seeing that bat Crush that dude's arm
is crazy a little bit too yeah it's a
little Stinger it's like this
long it's like somebody hit a fish with
[Laughter]
and he Club a seal dude did he fly this
guy's and he takes his time and lets the
arm get in there and comes down
everybody I'm about that yeah
uh scumbag move yeah but
we gotta wrap her up here gang gang I'm
gonna tell you this we love you we love
yous and we'll see you next week peace